[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada del día
hablamos de lo que estábamos también
conversando nuestros informativos y con
Rosa la reuniones en canciller alemán
olafchols con el presidente chino en una
controvertida visita Beijing donde
aseguró querer desarrollar aún más sus
relaciones económicas con el país
asiático y apeló para que china ejerza
su influencia sobre Rusia para poder
poner fin a la guerra en Ucrania
saludamos a Diana Luna ella es analista
internacional Diana muy buen día gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
América de Francia 24 hablemos o primero
entonces de la importancia de esta
visita alcanzará alemán olafchols a
China recordemos que es el primer líder
europeo eh No que visita presencialmente
china después se de la pandemia Y por
qué tan polémica criticado incluso
dentro de su propio partido
sí sin duda es una visita muy
controvertida dentro de la coalición de
semáforo porque la relación con china ha
dado frutos muy limitados Entonces ahora
se está buscando replantearse la
estrategia con china una estrategia en
la cual se puedan tomar en cuenta temas
relevantes como de Derechos Humanos pero
también se siga profundizando en la
relación comercial por eso es que es una
una visita muy controversial además el
tiempo es crítico justo hace dos semanas
hemos visto como chaschimpina ha
continuado centralizando el poder
entonces hay críticas dentro de la
opinión pública si este es el mejor
momento para llevar a cabo una visita de
estado y también digamos hay
preocupación o por esta dependencia que
vimos de Europa sobre todo de Alemania
que dependía mucho y depende de la
energía de Rusia no para su país
entonces claro la preocupación también
surgida que Qué nuevas acusaciones le va
a otorgar a China para evitar también
digamos que quieren los opositores sobre
todo evitar que tenga una nueva
dependencia con china en otra materia
comercial digamos
Sí de hecho dentro de la industria
privada Existen dos grupos un grupo que
está a favor de profundizar las
relaciones con China y otro grupo en
donde ven esta dependencia Peligrosa en
donde se busca más proteger intereses
desde nacionales y sobre todo la
infraestructura entonces sobre todo
porque la guerra ha dado a relucir que
hay una lección que aprender que es una
una dependencia excesiva en el caso por
ejemplo de de Alemania a Rusia en la
producción del gas
hacia Alemania más vulnerable por eso es
que en las últimas semanas ha habido un
gran debate respecto a a la concesión de
una participación limitada de la empresa
Estatal china Costco en la construcción
de una de las terminales del puerto de
algo porque vemos Que
china Busca la estrategia a nivel
europeo de comprar y de tener mayor
participación en sectores esenciales
como puertos y aeropuertos ahora también
Diana hablando de la guerra en Ucrania
recordemos que china es uno de los
grandes aliados de Rusia aunque no ha
apoyado directamente no al presidente de
la Emir Putin en su decisión de esta
invasión a Ucrania debido a esto también
el canciller al hermano olafachols en su
visita pues le dijo a Putin que pues
tratará de ejercer su influencia de
alguna manera para tratar de poner fin a
a esta guerra no que tanto puede ejercer
el poder las palabras de choles en la
decisión de putiné de tratar de mediar
con Rusia para el fin de la guerra esto
realmente lo es posible
bueno la diplomacia es fundamental para
para terminar con esta guerra y de hecho
en la unión pública en Alemania los las
últimas encuestas muestran que los
alemanes desean que los esfuerzos
diplomáticos sean mayores más de un 60%
Busca que se logren esfuerzos entonces
creo que en este sentido es importante
que Alemania sigas presionando para para
que haya paz y de hecho en esta visita
en el marco vemos que las declaraciones
sobre todo del gobierno chino son no
buscar más escalaciones militares porque
cualquier tipo de escalación militar
trae consecuencias en la cadena de
suministros y en la quena de producción
global por eso es que creo que Alemania
tiene que seguir presionando para que se
logre la paz Pero obviamente con una paz
que sea duradera y que está y recordando
que la invasión fue de parte de Rusia
hacia Ucrania claro
también para poner un poco más de
contexto en esta Visita cómo han sido
las relaciones el diplomáticas y también
y comerciales entre Alemania y China no
y qué tanta influencia tiene China en
los tiempos actuales en Alemania
hemos visto un cambio en la relación
bilateral cada vez en el aspecto
económico cada vez el déficit comercial
aumenta de Alemania hacia china hemos
visto también que
el hay que no hay una hay un trato
desigual de las empresas alemanas en
China sobre todo si lo comparamos como
empresas chinas son tratadas en Alemania
y también se ha visto que la estrategia
que hasta ahora el gobierno alemán había
buscado de transformar de democratizar a
China a través de de comercio a través
de de un acercamiento ha dado pocos
resultados por eso es que ahora ese
debate en los círculos políticos sobre
una nueva estrategia
respecto a China tanto en el ámbito
económico como en el político sino
olvidar
que en China se siguen dando violaciones
sistemáticas de Derechos Humanos a
minorías Claro que hay que decir lo que
una estrategia nacional respecto a China
no es suficiente Alemania tiene que
trabajar a nivel de la Unión Europea
para tener una estrategia
conjunta y común respecto a cómo
trabajar con china Diana a pesar de las
críticas ya lo vimos de hecho él se hizo
su visita a China no Esta visita es
rápida de apenas creo que 11 horas a la
capital a Beijing Esto va a tener
digamos consecuencias políticas sobre
todo dentro de la política interna
alemana dentro de de su partido Esto va
a tener un costo político para chores o
no va a trascender Más allá de estas
críticas iniciales a la visita
pues eso está por verse algo que nos hay
que tomar en cuenta que la última
encuesta dice que más del 50% de los
alemanes Busca que haya un cambio en la
red política en la estrategia de
Alemania hacia china Entonces vamos a
ver que si el Esta visita de shorts es
fructífera trae buenos resultados lo que
sí se puede decir De antemano es que ha
dado mucha controversia es criticada por
por muchos círculos políticos en
especial por los verdes y los liberales
que son socios dentro del gobierno se el
semáforo Porque no solo es no son no
puede ser una visita comercial como era
en los últimos con los últimos gobiernos
tienen que ser una visita diferente en
donde se donde se toquen temas de
derechos humanos de cambio climático y
donde también siga
enfocándose el el en donde también se
siga
mostrando que la guerra con en Ucrania
es es un es un error